contrario a lo que muchos esperaban en
que la salida de Pedro Castillo iría a
traer tranquilidad al Perú Esto no es
así en las últimas horas se han
registrado en la base de la diroes
protestas de simpatizantes de Pedro
paseo de Pedro Castillo exigiendo su
Liberación Mientras tanto se produce en
marchas de protesta y bloqueo de vías en
diferentes regiones del Perú exigiendo
el cierre del Congreso la renuncia de la
presidenta Dina boluarte y la
convocatoria a nuevas elecciones
justamente para este domingo ya está
programada la primera marcha de protesta
contra la nueva presidenta del Perú y es
que mientras Dina boluarte se reúne con
Los líderes de los partidos políticos
tratando de consolidar La tregua que
pidió
colectivos de izquierda y algunos
sectores radicales en la llaman traidora
del presidente Pedro Castillo Al haber
Jurado como nueva presidenta de los
peruanos Francisco también se habla de
suicidio político al cerrar el congreso
qué tan cierto es esto que se dice
Bueno en realidad el ex Primer Ministro
guido bellido ha denunciado que Pedro
Castillo habría sido inducido a cometer
error a leer el mensaje que se ordenaba
el cierre del Congreso justamente
bellido está diciendo que Pedro Castillo
no se encontraba en el uso de sus
facultades plenas y por eso está
exigiendo un examen toxicológico muchos
están culpando de esto a Aníbal Torres y
a la ex primer ministra Betsy Chávez
coincidentemente en las últimas horas
han aparecido unos chats del Consejo de
ministros donde Betsy Chávez el pasado 7
de diciembre a las 10:46 de la mañana
llamaba a los ministros a Palacio de
Gobierno porque se trataba de un momento
histórico para el país coincidentemente
a esa misma hora se redactaba el mensaje
que leyó Pedro Castillo muchos juristas
señalan que esto refuerza la tesis de la
Fiscalía de que se cometieron los
delitos de Rebe mi conspiración porque
hubo personas que estaban planificando
el cierre del Congreso esto deja sin
efecto a la defensa de Pedro Castillo
quien podría ser condenado a cumplir
Entre 10 a 20 años de prisión si es que
es hallado culpa